Moustache
Hier...
Non, c'était...
Avant-hier, j'étais comme toi :
Un style qui fait tache,
Une dégaine un peu louche,
J'étais mou sans ma 'stache
J'ai fini par changer
Pour un style qui fait mouche ;
Laisser pousser des ailes
Et des poils au-dessus d'la bouche
Si tu veux rentrer
dans ce club sélect
Pas b'soin de laisser passer
Il faut se laisser pousser
Une 'stache fournie façon Tom Sellec
Une moustache bio à la José Bové
Pas de pastiche
Ma moustache n'est pas factice
Pas d'hémistiche
quand
frappent les doubles croches
C'est fastoche, ma moustache
elle est gratis ;
J'ai la se-cla,
je l'affiche sur ma caboche
Moi j'tâte les miches des meufs michto
Si tu veux m'clasher,
mec faut qu'tu te lèves tôt !
J'ai pas ma moustache dans ma poche
Et si les dames en avaient,
je serais le barbier de ces filles.
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
Vous êtes prêts ?!
Ouais !
Rasés de près ?!
Non !
J'pars en freestache
Il ne faut plus hésiter ;
Joue pas les fines bouches
Travaille ta pilosité
Pas de barbe au cul
ni de poil au menton
Si tu chauffes le barbecue
J'te prépare le mouton
J'fais monter le mercure,
comme Freddy Mercury !
J'passe en mode hardcore,
l'étalon de l'écurie !
Je bas tous les r'cords
Meilleur qu'un poulet curry
Avec mon pull à carreaux
comme Pierre et Marie Curie !
Pas touche à la 'stache à papa,
ça te pends au nez
Joue pas la maline avec ta frange de poney
Tu me dis malhabile
mais toi t'es mal habillée
Range tes billes, tu t'es fait boulée
c'est plié !
Qui a dit qu'les hommes glabres étaient agréables ?
Moi les imberbes ça me rase
je les trouves barbants !
Je nique les peaux lisses comme des phoques--
Hein ?
Euh, oui, alors non,
en fait je parlais de "peau".
L'épiderme.
Tout doux, des "peaux lisses", comme...
des peaux de phoques.
L'animal.
Bibifoc. Vous connaissez ?
Ah.
Moustache
Dans ma Super 5 !
Dans mon potage aux légumes !
Moustache
Sur ma planche à roulettes !
Sur le ChatRoulette !
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
Toujours ma...
Moustache
Avec ma...
MOUSTACHE